hearing the dynamic between you two all
you hear is laughter like it's yeah you
guys awfully high you must have had an
awful time working together yeah it was
rough it was rough it's a lot of fun we
have a lot of fun you know if you're
still laughing at this point then you
know you're doing something right
because it's a monumental amount of work
to make one of these movies and and then
to go on and you know do the
post-production and then to go and
promote it and we've been having fun
this whole time that's great how does it
you know when you take on a franchise of
this magnitude and the amount of people
it takes to kind of make a movie like
this and then you get budgets involved
how do you deal with the pressure at the
various stages throughout it first of
all - that's a good question but I think
when we talk about a franchise of this
magnitude I would like to say a
franchise of this magnitude which is why
I found it very hilarious because I'm
very familiar with those but um I think
sit with with a movie like this I mean
we feel a sense of it's like
simultaneous like internal
responsibility and just like euphoric
wish-fulfillment Glee like it's the fact
that you mean we were kids when we watch
Jurassic Park and the theater like we
were like the kids it's like right the
perfect age to be like I will worship
Jurassic Park for the rest of my life
and so to get to be a part of this
there's the pressure of just like oh my
gosh I just don't want to mess it up but
there's also that fun you know of and
it's crazy are you are your kids at that
age where they watch it you're saying my
son is 11 so it's like perfect and my
daughter is 6 sure sure sure you know so
what some years later what about having
Jeff involved with the film having
watched the first one what's that like
the first moment you get to see him on
set I think you know it's cool it was
cool when he's on set and he's there and
he's I mean I'd met him before but never
in a capacity like that and and just
having him be so present in and so nice
to everybody it really felt like it was
an endorsement it was like hey I'm oh uh
he's from the original cast
and but he showed up to help us with
this movie begin it made us think like
we got the permission to do this you
know I mean granted Steven Spielberg
hired us so we I knew we have a mission
and people really love the movie when it
came out so but it's nice to get that
endorsement from someone well from the
original cast you know it feel it felt
really good there's that point where
he's sitting in front of the panel and
and they're talking about science yeah
this administration right now is there a
social commentary I think I think that
that when it comes to any kind of a
community of people there are their
differing beliefs and and there are
impossible choices that need to be made
because it's for the whole group and
even though some people believe
different things and I think that that's
kind of what sci-fi is about it's it's
about presenting these these like
cautionary tales and being like hey
group what would you guys do and so it's
in a way it's it's it helps us as a
society kind of deal with some of these
bigger bigger questions that we're gonna
have to answer in the near future so I
think that yeah this is these stories
are really relevant especially now with
everything that's happening with
technology and I mean I'm like I'm like
do I what are we gonna have to be
dealing with in 5-10 years even it's
gonna be a different world it really
does feel that way yeah when you guys
spend this much time together on set
what kind of shenanigans happening the
kind of ridiculous stuff happens like is
there any roars yes but we we prepare we
pretend that there are dinosaurs there
when sometimes there aren't that's
pretty ridiculous that's pretty yeah
yeah beyond what's inherently ridiculous
with making you know the embarrassment
of acting against something that is not
there I mean the end result it's
terrifying it looks so good but there
are some moments while you're making
them we're like you really gotta trust
your director you're like you got some
footage of me she's running and
screaming a flap of my arms and there's
nothing behind me I know you'll put a
dinosaur in there and it will all look
good you put music and look good but for
a brief moment you feel pretty
comparison acting is embarrassed it's
yeah